l'appel a été entendu les candidats se
succèdent à l'école militaire de beni
ces derniers jours objectif faire face
aux attaques régulières des rebelles de
l'adf groupes armés ougandais qui sévit
dans l'est du territoire congolais
depuis 1995 des pillages de villages à
mes dossiers des exactions sur les
populations civiles qui aurait fait au
moins 50 morts depuis début février
malgré de nombreuses interventions
l'armée congolaise peine à contenir les
assauts ennemis alors elle fait appel à
la population
il ya celle hackers compris des
intellectuels pour adhérer à n'est ce
pas alarmer ici à bemis ce sont les
candidats qui sont venues des butembo et
aussi essaient de béni alors au total
physiquement présent pour shooter qui
sont au nombre de 1846 qui sont datés
salle entraide et présenter leurs tests
ils ont commencé par la dissertation ils
sont à trets démontré combien ils sont
capables dé réfléchir déraisonnée les
candidats ont dû passer plusieurs tests
afin d'être admis dans les rangs de
l'armée
un choix patriotes pour un objectif
commun rétablir la paix dans cette
région de la rdc mais les maîtriser ses
dépenses au niveau des qualités n'est
pas empêché d'aller piger pour attirer
du sang neuf dans ses rangs les soldats
effectué des parades militaires aux
quatre coins de la région de béni et
l'appel semble entendue notamment par
les femmes est très peu représentée au
départ dans les rangs de l'armée
elles sont de plus en plus nombreux à
s'engager il manque on s'aime et les
dépose et matam nature
à l'école militaire c'est juste l'amour
de la patrie
l'amour des mots paix juste pour travail
travail pour mot paix que les femmes ne
peut et ne soit parfait que avec une
paire l'un qu'il sache bien que la
contribution peut aussi faire évoluer
notre pays
l'armée congolaise avait lancé fin 2010
9 une opération d'envergure contre les
rebelles de l'adf qui a permis de
déloger le groupe armé a dispersé les
combattants agissent désormais en petit
groupes mobiles selon des experts des
nations unies
les massacres régulier depuis 2014 ont
fait plus d'un millier de morts